a team of CBS News journalists got
extraordinary access inside a major New
York City Hospital battling the corona
virus they take viewers behind the
scenes at a Medical Center in the Bronx
as emergency doctors and nurses risk
their own lives to save patients many of
them from minority communities you can
see they're reporting in a one-hour
primetime special tonight bravery and
hope seven days on the front line let's
take an early look this is a gentleman
that we were called about yesterday for
some respiratory difficulty we put him
on higher amount of oxygen and he did
okay but this morning he's worse
now they're gonna get him ready for
intubation every one of these intubation
poses a risk to my doctors who are doing
it
bodily fluids from the lung oftentimes a
spewed into the air there are no small
emergencies they're all patients having
respiratory distress or cardiac arrest
have now attached him to the ventilator
and they're trying to get his oxygen up
and his blood pressure up and oftentimes
their simultaneous I need to go in this
nun in the car this is a typical day the
ventilator is here now
during the entire pandemic the stress
level has been very high as critical
care physicians we were used to taking
care of sickest patients in the hospital
but now we're taking care of a hospital
that has been the sickest as has ever
been
that is inside the Montefiore Medical
Center in the Bronx and you can watch
the 1-hour primetime special bravery and
hope seven days on the frontline tonight
at 9:00 8:00 central right here on CBS